it is time for spring cleaning and if
you don't know where to start
zerorez has got you covered well summer
is almost here and it is time to get
your home nice and clean especially if
you're gonna have visitors in the first
time in over a year
and the only people i would trust to
make my home
a clean safe space is xero rez ben mckee
joins us tell us about the zero rest
difference what makes you guys different
than everyone else
you know what makes us different is we
love what we do
from our technicians to our call center
to me i love cleaning carpet i love
cleaning floors i love the results
and we do it with a unique cleaning
process it's actually a patented system
that doesn't use any soaps or harsh
chemicals which is totally unique in
this
in the industry uh you don't have
crunchy carpets or weird odors
associated with the cleaning you're left
with clean carpets
that stay cleaner longer and are healthy
and hygienic
you just touched on that i've noticed
this when my carpets are clean
my carpets do stay cleaner longer and i
have a very light colored carpet
with other with other companies i've
noticed that they have to come in every
couple of months but not with zero res
why
is that well we've eliminated the need
for soap
we have to understand how soap works
soap is like a magnet for dirt
and a carpet cleaner can't remove all
that soap out of a carpet there's just
no way possible to do it
and so you're left behind you have
residue left behind that attracts dirt
and
causes your spots to come back and your
traffic lights that come back
and causes you to call up the
traditional carpet cleaner more often
one thing people with pets will always
complain about is there's just no way
you're going to be able to get out my
pet stains or my pet odors
but xero rez you can do it
that's right you don't have to throw
away your carpets give us a call
we can most more to likely save them for
you we have an
arsenal of products that safely and
effectively go after not only the stain
but we can actually remove
the products causing the odor so you can
get that eliminated
and go back to having a clean fresh home
let's talk about your ratings
and your reviews i know i am a fan and
but we take these really
seriously when we recommend our vendors
and zerorez
is rated number one you guys have over
15 000 stellar reviews why do you think
that is
this is what we live and die for we love
cleaning we love providing the best
customer experience
in fact every morning for about an hour
our team is trained
primarily on providing customer service
you know that the technical stuff is
important and we do a really good job
with that
but our focus is making sure that you
feel comfortable and safe with us in
your home
or in your business and that the results
that we provide are
second to none you're making getting
your carpets clean
really fun right now because you have a
cool partnership with cowabunga bay tell
us a little bit about this
it is it's amazing right now you can get
three rooms of carpet pre-treated
cleaned and zero resified for only 99
and for a limited time we're gonna throw
in two cowabunga bay
day passes uh just as a free gift from
zero red so get ready for memorial day
get your carpets cleaned
take advantage of that special their
memorial day special three rooms of
carpet cleaned
for only 99 plus get two free passes to
cowabunga bay las vegas
number one water park with 23 acres of
summer fun thrilling water slides and
amazing food
give zero res a call at 702-840-3333 or
find them online
zerorezlis.com minimum supply
las vegas now will be